[Música]
sigue las reacciones al anuncio del
presidente salvadoreño en nayib bukele
quien manifestó su intención de
presentarse a un segundo mandato experto
señalan que se trata de una violación a
la Carta Magna que prohíbe la reelección
presidencial inmediata en el país
regresan a Venezuela 12 de los 19
tripulantes del avión de la compañía
Estatal entre Sur que habían estado
retenidos desde junio en Argentina en
medio de una investigación por supuestos
vínculos con terrorismo los otros siete
integrantes y la aeronave permanecen en
Buenos Aires Tenemos reporte desde
Caracas
en Estados Unidos Virginia occidental se
convierte en el segundo estado en
promulgar una ley que prohíbe la
interrupción del embarazo Desde que la
Corte Suprema de Justicia revocó su
Amparo constitucional la medida de
restringe este procedimiento en todas
las etapas de gestación con algunas
excepciones
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias de
América en France 24 los saluda Andrés
Meza Muñoz empezamos en El Salvador el
anuncio del presidente nayib bukele de
presentarse un segundo mandato en las
próximas elecciones ha causado revuelo
en el país y a la comunidad
internacional de acuerdo con la
Constitución el mandatario no puede
aspirar a una reelección inmediata pero
un fallo de la sala de lo constitucional
de la Corte Suprema en 2021 abrió la
puerta para que buque le pueda ser
candidato previamente conversamos con
José Miguel viván con miembro adjunto de
Derechos Humanos en el consejo de
relaciones exteriores cfr y ex director
para las Américas de Human right watch
le preguntamos y la decisión de bukele
se puede considerar como una violación
del Estado de derecho creo que es parte
del libreto el mismo libreto que usó
Chávez y que han usado otros
déspotas autoritarios en la región para
buscar perpetuarse en el poder una nada
más que eso ese es una operación
relativamente sencilla hace
un poco más de un año porque le logró el
control total del Congreso
y valiéndose de ese control descabezó a
los jueces de la Corte Suprema que eran
bastante independientes y que
resguardaban el espíritu y la letra de
la Constitución y la Constitución es
absolutamente inequívoca en este punto
un presidente electo que ya está en
funciones no puede aspirar a un segundo
periodo sin embargo esa nueva
sala de la Corte Suprema con jueces
afines a bukele decidió por si ante sí
darle una interpretación
yo diría Absurda y contraria al al texto
literal de la Constitución y abrir las
puertas para que buquele se postulara
nuevamente algo que lo anunció el día de
ayer y Lamentablemente Reproduce replica
lo que es usual en en otros casos en
América Latina donde
mandatarios que son electos
democráticamente luego persiguen
quedarse en el poder y violar normas
elementales del Estado derecho y de la
propia Constitución y ya se encuentran
en Caracas los 12 tripulantes del avión
de la empresa Estatal venezolana entra
Sur que habían permanecido retenidos en
la capital Argentina desde junio entre
ellos están 11 venezolanos y un iraní
que llegaron al Aeropuerto Internacional
de maiquetía las autoridades argentinas
investigaban posibles vínculos con
terrorismo internacional ya que la
aeronave perteneció a la aerolínea iraní
majar Air sancionada por Estados Unidos
el avión sigue retenido en Argentina
junto con los otros siete integrantes
del grupo desde Caracas nuestra
corresponsal Daniela Zambrano con los
detalles Este primer grupo de
tripulantes liberados por la justicia
Argentina río territorio venezolano
cerca de las 6:30 de la tarde hora local
fueron recibidos al Aeropuerto
Internacional de maiquetía por
familiares entre aplausos ovaciones
también estaba presente personal de la
cancillería y el ministro del transporte
que calificó esta detención como me
gusta algunos de los liberados
declararon a medios de comunicación que
ellos no eran ni terroristas ni espías
Cómo se les había calificado y exigieron
la liberación de sus compañeros que
todavía pertenece permanecen en
territorio argentino se trataría de tres
ciudadanos venezolanos y cuatro iraníes
entre ellos el piloto y el copiloto de
la aeronave recordemos que este avión de
la empresa entra Sur filial de la
venezolana conviasa fue detenido el
pasado mes de junio junto a su
tripulación luego que el departamento de
justicia de Estados Unidos solicitara la
incautación de la aeronave por presuntos
vínculos con el terrorismo Aunque el
avión este funcionaba bajo la empresa
entra Sur según el departamento de
justicia de Estados Unidos pertenecía a
una aerolínea iraní que está sancionada
que está en la lista negra de sancionada
por presuntos vínculos con
organizaciones terroristas como hezbola
el presidente Nicolás Maduro calificó la
acción como un secuestro y exigido se
devuelva la aeronave vamos a Estados
Unidos en el estado de Virginia
occidental en vigor una ley que prohíbe
el aborto en todas las etapas del
embarazo con algunas excepciones es el
segundo estado que prohíbe el aborto
luego de que el tribunal supremo de
Estados Unidos revocara en junio el
fallo rojo versus wade que desde 1973
protegía el derecho a la interrupción
del embarazo a nivel Federal desde
Washington nuestro corresponsal
Cristóbal Vázquez Nos daba todos los
detalles sobre esta nueva ley
si hoy firmó Justice gobernador del
estado de Virginia occidental esta ley y
pone de inmediato la aplicación de esta
ley en 90 días las penalidades asociadas
a esta higiene occidental se convierte
entonces en el segundo estado en Estados
Unidos en prohibir el aborto después de
que la Corte Suprema de Justicia Pues
fallara en contra del derecho al aborto
a nivel Federal hay que mencionar que
las excepciones a esta ley son la
violación el incesto y riesgos de salud
en la madre sin embargo los abortos se
tendrán que hacer en las primeras ocho
semanas en caso de adultos o 14 semanas
en caso de menores los médicos que se
atrevan a Pues proveer los abortos
corren el riesgo de durar 10 años en la
cárcel y este tema es bastante
importante teniendo en cuenta que las
encuestas recientes dicen que el tema
del aborto es el que más participación
ha generado tanto en la población
votante demócrata y republicana Así que
va a ser un tema muy importante para las
elecciones legislativas en noviembre y
presidenciales en dos años en otras
noticias de Estados Unidos continúa la
batalla judicial por el material
incautado de la residencia de la
expresidente Donald Trump en Florida el
departamento de justicia solicitó a una
corte de apelaciones que revierta la
orden de la jueza Aylin Canon que
suspendió la revisión de los documentos
denominados como clasificados y que
fueron recuperados de la mansión del ex
mandatario un día antes la misma jueza
había designado al veterano magistrado
reymond dirty como perito especial para
revisar dichos papeles entre los que se
encuentran decenas de documentos
clasificados el departamento de Justicia
dice que la decisión de la jueza le
obstaculiza los esfuerzos del gobierno
para proteger la seguridad nacional el
conflicto entre los productores de coca
de la zona de los yungas de Bolivia
divididos entre A fines y contrarios al
gobierno llevan varios meses sin
solución los enfrentamientos en los
enfrentamientos se usa constantemente
vietnamita Pese a que está prohibido por
la ley decenas de personas han resultado
heridas los dos bandos han anunciado
para el lunes nuevas movilizaciones
las explosiones de dinamita en la
disputa entre cocaleros rivales por el
control del mercado de la coca de la paz
están causando miedo y caos pero su uso
se ha vuelto rutinario en el conflicto
poniendo en riesgo la vida de los
propios manifestantes
tras una explosión ocurrida en una
protesta el pasado mes de agosto el
cocalero Plácido Cota resultó gravemente
herido Y aunque logró quedar con vida
perdió su brazo izquierdo
agradecer
hacia el hospital
por vivir una segunda vez
la policía ha detenido a manifestantes
del bando cocalero antigubernamental por
tener explosivos sin embargo los dos
sectores enfrentados los han usado para
atacarse causando varios lesionados los
contrarios al gobierno aseguran que se
defienden de la represión
lo usan para defenderse porque no tienen
otro argumento cuando ya son rebasados
no son escuchados la policía también
reprime la protesta con explosivos nació
en las rebeliones mineras contra las
dictaduras militares un legislador
minero pidió al parlamento que la
dinamita sea declarada patrimonio
cultural del país pero la propuesta fue
vetada el senador que frenó la idea
advierte sobre una ambigüedad en el
gobierno
cuando el movimiento social un grupo es
afín al gobierno
metadinamita cuando el grupo es
contrario como el caso de adeccoca la
dinamita se vuelve un conflicto social o
de posible daño a la sociedad no
el barrio de la paz que se ha convertido
en el campo de batalla de los dos bandos
pide Paz Mientras tanto los vecinos han
construido barricadas en sus calles para
protegerse
y cerramos en Broadway que le dirá adiós
a uno de los espectáculos más icónicos y
el más longevo se trata del musical El
fantasma de la ópera cuyas funciones han
sido permanentes desde 1988 a excepción
de la pandemia y que ha sobrevivido a
recesiones y otros cambios culturales
pero ahora se despide del público tras
una disminución en la taquilla que
impacta directamente en los elevados
costos de la producción vestuario y
elenco se espera que el show cierre con
13.925 funciones acumuladas la última
será el 18 de febrero de 2023
hasta que este informativo Gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]